[Music]
my name is derek wenji from the cobblers
today i'm going to walk you through how
me and my team restore the midsole of
this bread 2012 jordan 4. the shoe we're
working on today specifically is the
bread 12 which is a nickname for black
and red which is very common which you
find in jordan's
the value of the shoe and the condition
that it came in is probably around 200
to 225 dollars
if you're lucky enough to find a pair
that no one has worn in the last nine
years you're looking at about 550 for
the value of the shoe if you have all
the original accessories in the box
[Music]
you're going to be removing all the
paint from the midsole to prep the
midsole for new paint
we're then going to lay down some base
layers of white and finish it up with a
solid white coat then we're going to go
ahead and tape up that white to add our
second color which is black so it looks
original
[Music]
the shoe is nine years old which is
another reason why this shoe needs to be
repainted because it's been worn a
little bit and the paint's starting to
crack
the most difficult part of this
restoration is keeping the midsoles
looking smooth and factory clean
the issue that we have as these shoes
start to age is that the eva foam which
is what the midsole is comprised of
starts to break down it's our job to try
and keep that looking original and
smooth by removing the paint safely
depending on the type of shoe the type
of paint as well as the age of the shoe
the paint on the midsole starting to
chip on the shoe because it's from 2012
so we're going to go ahead and remove
all this paint to get started we're
actually using a dull blade to scrape
away this paint carefully
depending on the year and the model of
shoe they use different types of paints
on these 2012 bread fours it's actually
acrylic paint you can tell because it's
a little bit flaky and that's we're
going to be chipping it away as opposed
to using a solvent or other type of
chemical to remove that
it's necessary to remove the old paint
so we can get a nice clean surface to
adhere to this allows the paint to be
flexible durable and to give us the
smoothest finish possible when removing
the paint with this method we really
want to focus on scraping just the paint
and not digging down into that eva foam
midsole
so once we have the majority if not all
of the paint removed from scraping i'm
going to go ahead and go back with some
denatured alcohol or isopropyl alcohol
works as well to just wipe down the
surface to make sure i've got any debris
or oil that might have built up on that
midsole
[Music]
so once we've removed all that original
paint and cleaned it with alcohol we're
going to go ahead and start with our
base coats of white
before adding that paint i'm going to go
ahead and tape up these areas to make
sure i don't get paint on any areas that
i don't want it
the trick here for taping off is just to
take your time and really make sure
you're putting your tape where you need
it once you've applied it i always like
to take a step back and look at it to
make sure i have a second eye or a
second angle to make sure i did that
accurately
almost every time we're repainting
midsoles i'm going to use a base layer
of paint which is actually just the
color i'm using when i'm first painting
in this case it's going to be white
before i do the black so i'm going to do
some light coats of white to build up
the base and then do more coats of white
to get a full solid color
when i'm applying the white paint as the
base layer i make sure i apply that all
over for a few coats but once i have
about two coats down as a base coat i'll
then focus on the area where the white
paint is actually visible once we're
gonna be done with the paint job in this
case that's going to be on the bottom of
the midsole as the top is going to be
black
so once we finish the white paint you
can see it's a nice solid color on the
bottom and now we need to do the top
which is going to be black for this i'm
going to be using a quarter inch blue
painters tape to tape off the bottom so
i can put the black paint on top cleanly
you can use any tape you really want you
just need to make sure you can get a
clean crisp edge
[Music]
when we're applying this tape for the
second color we need to be very precise
on this particular shoe there is a
little ledge here that i can tuck the
tape underneath which gives me a little
guide to make sure i can line this up
properly if the tape is not placed
carefully you're going to alter that
line it's not going to be a smooth
straight finish and it's not going to
look factory
the type of paint we're using today is
angelus paint it's specifically designed
for leather and sneakers in general it's
a very flexible durable paint that we
love to use here
when i'm painting i try to focus on
stretching the paint out as much as
possible and making that a really thin
coat if we're using too much paint it's
going to be too thick and it's going to
crack when the customer wears it we're
also going to get some brush strokes we
want to make sure these are very thin
coats that we're trying to spread out
evenly
[Music]
on this shoe you can see that i chose
not to tape off the upper of the shoe
that's because of two reasons the upper
on the shoe is delicate based off the
material and also i don't want to get
any paint on that upper so i'd rather
trust my eye than the tape to stop the
paint
so once i put on that last coat of black
and that color is looking full i can go
ahead and remove all the tape but i need
to allow this to dry for five to ten
minutes so the paint is fully cured
[Music]
the paint will cure fully over the next
24 hours so we recommend the customers
don't wear that just needs to wait 24
hours so you can get them back on the
streets